Through the archaeological objects displayed in the pavilions, it is confirmed that our
land has been inhabited by the Illyrians, our predecessors, and the Albanians in continuity
as early back as four thousand years ago.
The exhibited archaeological objects are authentic-like arms, ceramics, and bronze decorating objects.
Since antiquity, our land was a target of various invasions and was attacked by Romans
and after three Illyrian-Roman wars, the country was invaded by them in the year 168 BC.
Nevertheless, neither the Roman invasion nor the Slavic eruption in the sixth century couldn't
assimilate the native population.
This phenomenon is an example of the ethnocultural resistance of the Albanian people who founded
the first state of Arbor in 1190.
In the antiquity pavilion are displayed the following objects.
Objects of pre-Civic Illyrian age, 8th until 6th century BC.
Civic Illyrian cultural objects, 4th until 3rd century BC.
Model of Libernship.
Illyrian ceramics, 3rd until 1st century BC.
Illyrian coins, 3rd until 2nd century BC.
The antique city of Albanopolis and some archaeological objects about its soil.
Statue of Artemis.
Illyrian arms.
Pyrrho, Tuta.
Illyrian-Roman wars.
Ceramics from the Middle Ages.
Emblem of Arbor princedom.
Map of Arbor princedom.